hey man it's me Kevin Smith I am up here
in Vancouver directing my third episode
of the flash and I'm gonna bring all of
you inside the stages with me come on
[Music]
this is the hallway of the cortex the
cortex is the main set on the flash it's
kind of like the Flash's Clubhouse get
down to the cortex like right now Grant
Gustin ladies and gentlemen the flash
himself fastest man alive nay best
dancer alive look at this move he just
fell into that you were doing it first
we've seen you sing and dance I'll be
there in a flash
Barry how was that it was weird because
we had glee people up here like Darren
Criss put a little love in your heart
over the course of four years we've
watched you go from oh that's that girl
that Barry grew up with and likes to
this season the leader of team flash
seven officers in Arcis agents down was
it like watching iris as character
develop over four seasons it's amazing
and I feel like the last time we did
this sort of interview you were asking
me what would it be like for you to suit
up and here we are this season we're
finally seeing her suit up so that's
already cool I'll take it from here
now that you've run what's left I don't
know what it's left I hope there's
something so I can keep jobs people are
speculating about children I mean that's
the next step in a marriage so who knows
maybe of all we'll see iris full belly
and with child or two
if you love Cisco's lines there's a good
chance that Carlos came up with it
that's right how do you know that forget
it I don't care
Thank You Todd he'll be letting me
change virtually every line in the
episodes this thing we got going on this
is the first big thing that I remember
you from was sky high which also ties in
to flash by costumes a long time let's
go I believe in only using my powers
when the situation demands it it's
incredible how they've changed you know
I'm sky high Kurt's costume had a
cooling system inside of it that like
had cold water running through it to
keep him cool you know obviously
Graham's suit is a little bit more
form-fitting so there's none of that
yeah there's no cooling on that's a
little snug the suit is very cool but is
it a pain in the ass to where she's like
hot like today but I think as far as
superhero suits go it's pretty
functioning these howdy questions is
what Skyy attract just call for cut
ladies jump hey everybody it's Charlie
we got a whole bunch of new flash and
arrow verse stuff to talk about they
just confirmed that pretty much
everything on the CW has been renewed
for a new season so I'll explained that
but they were actually a couple funny
moments during that promo where they
give you an idea of like where their
headspace is going for future seasons so
I will talk about my predictions for
flash season five at this point but
obviously we still have several episodes
to go this season so there's always the
opportunity they could take either a
really good or really bad left turn
so as we go along we can just edit our
predictions just based on new
information but if you're finding me for
the first time be sure to subscribe to
get all the videos there's a new round
of that flash ring giveaway hell yeah we
got season five so the funny thing the
Candice Patton says during this is that
she's like you know what's next for you
you got to wear the suit you got to be a
speedster for an episode like what else
is there she just chuckles a little bit
and says you know I hope there's
something so that I get to keep my job
then acknowledges all the speculation
about what's going on with Barry and
iris children in the future too because
I mean eventually at some point they
will have to have children so that you
can have the line of flashes you can get
to Bart Allen's you can do all that
stuff from the comics it's just a matter
of when not a matter of if so when she
does say you know people are speculating
about Iris and Barry having a child
maybe we'll see iris with a full belly
she probably doesn't know when they plan
on doing that they're still meant to be
very young so it would be weird if she
just automatically got pregnant right
away but because it's the flash we have
all these crazy twists with time travel
duplicates pretty much any sci-fi trope
you could think of if you're a big Buffy
Angel fan they did children on that show
with a couple big twists so that they
could actually do children without
having to make you sit through a couple
seasons of doing it the slow way so the
flash could always find a way to do
Barry and iris children without actually
having to get iris super visibly
pregnant on the TV show so just be
prepared for that but if you're a big
Joss Whedon fan and you watched all
those odd shows you've seen pretty much
every big sci-fi twist there is so you
probably won't be surprised with
whatever they end up doing but we get a
little more footage of Harrison wells in
the thinking cap he's starting to get
more and more addicted to that I know
people are wondering if he's gonna
become a future villain it's always
possible that that's the case but the
series seems like it has a more hopeful
spin so I'll be interested to see what
they do with Tom Cavanagh in season 5 I
will address season 5 predictions in a
second too but I love Carlos joking
about how he changes all of Cisco's
lines and episodes sometimes that's good
sometimes that's bad I still think the
Cisco season 1 season 2 was written a
little bit better and then there's just
like that funny conversation with
danielle Panabaker where they talk about
sky high I don't think I've ever seen an
interview with her with like another big
comic book person where sky high isn't
name dropped at least once and that was
more than 10 years ago like it doesn't
seem like that long ago but that was a
long time ago talking about season 5
stuff I'll address the other CW shows
too so big season 5 stuff is really
getting the show back to a more balanced
state like they swung from like really
depressing emo Berry during season 3 to
super happy jokey over-the-top at the
beginning of season 4 the way they wrote
Ralph didney with that whole Three
Stooges routine the first couple of
episodes that's probably the best
example of them taking it way too far
then you can tell they sort of
recalibrated a little bit especially at
the mid-season finale so Ralph right now
is a little bit better we don't know if
he's going to be coming back on the show
next season I think part of the twist
with the new
that allows them to swap DNA is the way
you keep Ralph on the show but take his
powers because previously when you took
someone's powers do you never like
completely take their body it ended up
killing them so if this were happening a
couple of episodes ago she takes Ralph's
powers
Ralph is gone but now because of what
happened with beer and Irish swapping
powers I think that's them foreshadowing
that the thinker gets those other bus
metas without having to kill everybody
else so if they do choose to do that big
comic book twist where thinker is fused
with flash they can actually do it with
the Neal salyanz' version without having
to actually jump into Barry's body so
you can have Grant Gustin and Hartley
Sawyer running around being their normal
characters just D powered because the
thinker has stolen their abilities so
with either just clearing room in case
they want to bring the elongated man
back next season but I am actually
hoping that they slim team flash down a
little bit and because we had that last
big twist with iris going back to being
a reporter or at least that's what she
implies that she's going to be doing it
sounds like that's what she'll be doing
next season regardless of whether or not
we go back to central city picture news
they might just have her be a reporter
blogger style like she was during season
one Cisco's pretty self explanatory he's
probably gonna become the new leader if
Harrison wells is gonna be around that
much or if he's gonna still be the
earth-2 version of his character the
thing with Tom Cavanagh is he's very
unpredictable like they always roll out
different personalities so depending on
how crazy he gets with this thinking cap
arc that could go any number of
directions but I think Cisco is one of
the few people that's gonna stay put so
it just makes sense that he would step
up and become the new team leader at
STAR Labs Caitlin is a bit of a question
mark because you know I really love
danielle Panabaker
I love what she does with Caitlin I've
enjoyed previous versions of killer
frost but I'd rather that they pick one
or the other and just stick with it like
give us a season of killer frost or give
us a season of Caitlin and I feel like
you can't go back to Caitlin after doing
really awesome versions of killer frost
like we want her in the costume we want
the sassy Caitlin that will just say
anything that's on her mind
she balances the team out a little bit
when Harrison wells isn't being a super
big [ __ ] like during season two like
there's always one person on the team
that's kind of an [ __ ] that balances
out the really happy people in terms of
really big villains I mean there's a
number of twists that they could take I
would love to see them do a Bart Allen
season to the flash it feels kind of
early for them to do that so that might
not be till season 6 season 7 but if
they are gonna do Barry iris children it
would make sense that they try to use
some time-travel aspects where you have
things that the children do in the
future that are bad that Barry and iris
have to fix but you also get children in
present day so you get a couple
different versions like look at this
person that's so awesome how could they
ever do something that was terrible cut
to that Back to the Future ending where
Doc Brown shows up and says Marty
there's a brand new problem it's your
children I'd be totally fine with him
doing another speedster villain they
burned some of the big ones it would be
fun to see what they're gonna do with
the new version of the reverse-flash but
I don't know if they would use that
character as the main villain of season
five so the big question I think is is
do you want another speedster villain
you know like tried true classic story
or do you want to see them try and turn
one of the team flash characters into a
villain like killer frost becomes the
villain of a season or do you want it to
be more of a time-travel twist where you
have a mixture of good characters like
Barry and irises children that are
villains so they become antagonists even
though they're not straight-up villains
but we're gonna need more diapers
everybody leave your theories in the
comments below what do you want them to
do with season 5 so because flash is
back next week there might be a new
promo tomorrow if there is I'll totally
do a video for it but just leave all
your bonus video requests in the
comments below and I'll name a new
giveaway winner when I post new DC click
here for brand new flash Godspeed and
click here for brand new infinity war
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome we'll see you guys tonight